Okay? That's what they're really [__]
doing. I'm not stupid. Okay, one second.
I just want to ask Myron, what do you
mean by you're not stupid? Like, who who
are you trying to prove what to? I don't
understand. Is someone trying to catch
you out? Whose back have you got? Like,
are they coming for your family? That
you're like, "Listen, I'm not stupid. I
know what you're trying to do. You're
trying to come and kill my family."
We are teaching people how to pray.
>> And every time they pray, you get to
share in that reward. And when they
teach their children and their
children's children
the reward continues. Every Fajr Dhuhr,
Asr, Maghrib, Isha Tarawih Tahajjud
Every recitation you share in the
reward. For just £100 you can help teach
20 to 60 people
>> like me learn how to pray salah. Donate
today. Donate today. Donate today.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys are well,
inshallah. I'm just quickly filming this
reaction video and I'm going to be
heading off to meet Sneako, I am born as
25s, Muhammad and Jab, Zeeshan um and
the rest of the brothers, inshallah.
We're going to go We're going to be
streaming all day today. If you guys
want to watch this, you can tonight cuz
the video will be coming out. This video
will be coming out today and you will
get to watch it. We're streaming
throughout the night, inshallah. With
them, it's a little link-up in Ramadan,
inshallah. And my aim is to get them,
inshallah, to the Let's Play a Game
podcast and maybe the Da'wah Bros
podcast tomorrow. We've got some good
stuff coming out. But, I want to do this
video because Myron has been really
really um
annoying me. I don't I don't understand
what his problem is. I don't know what
Does he have an inferiority complex? And
I don't mean to look any disrespect. I
don't do these videos just for like just
for the clout or just for the sake of
it, but it's agitating and annoying to
see Myron. He's a Muslim brother.
I don't I He's It's It's admitted he
doesn't practice, okay? But, he He says
stuff and I'm just like, "Who are you
trying to please? What is your point?"
Here's a video between um
Sneako and himself and Sneako reacting
to having a discussion with him about
the Times Square thing that brother SQ
did. Alhamdulillah, they did a beautiful
thing in Times Square. Didn't block
anywhere. Didn't take the whole place
off like the celebration of the Zionist
Israelis. Yes, it was a small place
where they were praying and that's it.
Reciting the Quran. Here's the video,
let's watch it for ourselves.
Okay, that's what they're really [__]
doing. I'm not stupid.
Okay, one second. I just want to ask
Myron, what do you mean by you're not
stupid? Like who who are you trying to
prove what to? I don't understand. Like
what do you mean you're not stupid? Is
someone trying to catch you out? Whose
back have you got? Like are they coming
for your family? Like you're like,
"Listen, I'm not stupid. I know what
you're trying to do. You're trying to
come and kill my family."
What do you mean by you're not stupid?
What do you mean by that? I don't
understand what you mean by that. Um
number one, there's going to be clarity
given of what did they take over? Did
they block the whole of Times Square?
I've been to Times Square before. It's
humongous. It's bigger as a three, four
times the size of um Piccadilly Circus
that we have here.
What do you mean? Like I'm not stupid. I
know what you're doing. Whose life is in
danger? Myron, I just feel like you've
got a chip on your shoulder, bro.
I feel like you've got a chip on your
shoulder. Like what is it that you're
trying to prove who to? Is it like is it
your followers? You're trying to show
your loyalty to the Americans of America
first? What is it?
Let's just call a spade a spade, ALL
RIGHT? I PROBABLY OWE YOU MUSLIMS AN
APOLOGY. When they're shutting down
Times Square, WHEN THEY'RE [__]
BLOCKING OFF THE STREET, WHEN THEY'RE
DOING THAT DAMN FIVE TIMES A DAY, IT'S A
CERTAIN [__] DOMINANCE. What what do
you mean? Who who stops I don't
understand.
I mean, if you if I don't know if you
pray. As far as I know, you don't pray
prayer. When I pray, I go to a little
corner somewhere without blocking and
and the prophet Muhammad told us it's
not permissible for you to block
pathways. It's not permissible. So, they
were not doing that. And not only that,
if you're someone that prays and
practices and prays five daily prayers,
I would pray bro I've prayed in all kind
of places, bro. All kind of places, bro.
I don't block anyone's pathway. I'm sure
I'm making sure no one's pathway is
blocked. So, what are you talking about?
Are you trying to impress your America
first audience? What is it? I I
genuinely think there's a chip on your
shoulder, bro. What is it?
I think I get what Sneako's doing there.
I was just thinking, "Why does he keep
doing that? Going back to that." I think
he's trying to make a point here. If
there's anyone that's blocking the whole
of Times Square
is the Zionists, Israelis.
I think that's what Sneako's doing. And
if you put your Sneako the one in that
THEN I [__] WILL CUZ YOU GUYS ARE
[__] LIARS.
He's calling Muslims liars.
IT'S A CERTAIN dominance that let people
know that we're coming. So firstly look
at the look with all due respect Myron,
you're not a practicing Muslim. And I'm
not saying there's anything like of
course there's something wrong with
that, not practicing your faith. There's
something wrong with that. I don't let
me not show you the quote here. But
there's always hope for you. We don't
look down on other words. You can be
better than me, bro. You can be much
better than me. I'm not saying this in
that manner.
You
you claim like sleeping with women and
do this. You promote you promote this
degeneracy and all this kind of stuff,
okay? If anything Islamically we don't
take your word. anything Islamically
because you're doing evil deeds. You're
known as an open fascist, an open evil
doer. And again I don't mean it
disrespectfully. I'm telling you what
Islam's position is this. And then
you're calling Muslims who are
practicing their faith, praying in
Tarawih, praying Tarawih in times of
whatever they're praying, they're liars.
The prophet peace be upon him said the
believer is anything but a liar. So if
anything we will take their word and
Sneako's word
over yours.
With all due respect. Yeah, so this is
me going around again. If you guys uh
remember you heard some of that
conversation.
>> saying is as a guest
Right, because we are we are guests
here. I What do you What does that mean
guest? We're guests. It's not a Muslim
country. It's not a Muslim country.
Or then you could make an argument that
it's a Jewish country if they control
98% of the population. Yeah, but this
guy So I mean let's it's a it's a
freedom of religion country. It's a
secular country. Technically Myron's
right. This is this is not our country.
I mean this is not it is not your
country. I mean uh Sneako might say that
he's born in that country, but my friend
when time comes, bro, you're going. They
take All you're going. All you guys are
going. They have a specific criteria,
bro. The Aryan bloodline. Yes, you are
going. Everyone's going. Let's Here I'll
be honest. Technically yes,
what Myron's saying is
they'll kick you all out. No, I'm not a
guest here. It's my country. I'm here in
New York City. I was born here.
98% of so many of these people that are
even talking about the spreading out
rage they're not from here.
They're not from here.
This is this is my country. It's not
going to change. What What are you
doing? I can't argue with
Sneako here with all due respect. I'm
going to see him soon. But it Yes, like
here I would say I'm born here. It's my
country. They'll kick me out, bro. They
will kick me out. When the time comes
they'll say listen, my friend. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye. I'm a citizen here. I'm not a
guest. I was No, no, no, no. Hold on.
hold on. I'm not a guest. I want to have
a passport. born
All I'm saying is all I'm saying is the
Islamic faith is not of course it's your
country but what I'm saying is that the
Islamic faith is not a part of the
American infrastructure.
>> Neither is Christianity.
>> this country was founded by Christian. A
good sniff of it a good point. Yes, all
right. Islam is not in a part of the
infrastructure but so then so is not
Christianity. Now you can say
they were Christians or Abraham Lincoln
or whatever for that matter still is it
values on Christian nation. Now I
believe it is a Christian nation because
they get married in the church, they
buried in the church in the name of God
and that's so when I go to America I can
eat their meat. I can eat it
it's permissible. However, to say it's
like it is a Christian no there's a lot
of liberalism there so it's it's a
divide but I would say it is a Christian
country per se in that argument. But
it's not part of the American doctrine.
The people that founded this country
It's not in the it's not in the
doctrine. Separation of church and state
was put in place so that either would
not corrupt each other but it's still a
Christian country founded by Christian
people. Right? Cuz you can make the
argument But it's not it's not a
Christian You can make the argument like
Syria wasn't a Muslim country isn't a
Muslim country because Bashar al-Assad
was a sec- it was a secularist or
something like that was a secularist.
It's still a Muslim country majority And
They're going to play that card. I'll
say that yeah it's a Christian majority
country but it's not a Christian country
by definition. I think this is a
Christian country. But there's no
there's no paperwork or any like it's
not in the constitution. It was founded
it's not a well
Yeah Islamic we even didn't decide what
makes a Muslim country, you know, is it
the ruler is it the amount of Muslims
are living in it.
So again it's it's a thin line. Is it a
Christian country? I deem it to be a
Christian country
but then you can see how the liberal
etc. what's going on with
you know the LGBTQ and the liberal
values. So
it's still a Christian country but it's
it's a thin line it's a thin line. So
I'm just yeah. They they have God in it.
And you when you pledge allegiance as an
American I grew up by I pledge
allegiance saying by God the God is
mentioned in the You say Jesus? You
don't say God. You don't say Jesus. You
say God. You don't have to say Jesus cuz
you say the Holy Spirit. To them God
Jesus are synonymous
synonymous.
>> Yes and no actually. If you talk to a
Christian
>> on who you talk to. Yeah be honest bro.
Yeah yeah I mean it's it's a bit
technicalities. I mean it doesn't really
matter. It is I would say it's a
Christian country and to them God slash
is when they say God they are Christians
in that sense, you know, even though
they believe Jesus is God. Uh you know,
but anyway, that's a different
theological discussion. But they they
they look at they look at God and Jesus
as the same. Like because he's the son
of God, so they He's also God's only
begotten son. So, they are separate
entities.
>> on who you look at or who who you're
asking. That's what I'm saying. That's a
different conversation. But the reason
that this is in God We Trust is because
it's the most universal statement. Yes,
but the point I'm trying to make is is
that regardless, this country was
founded by Christians. They reserved the
right to run the country however they
want. And if they do want to play
church, I'll take it a step further. If
they want to play the church bells, I
think they can be Okay, that's fine. I
mean, I I agree with that, you know,
this this it is a Christian country. And
at the end of the day, look, one thing
we need to understand is the following,
okay?
In the Sharia law, they cannot do that.
Like they cannot come to a Muslim area
and Christian start singing. And in
neither the Judaism. We are religion, we
have a specific set of set rules.
However, this is where you need to
understand the nuance. However, liberal
worldview, liberal values, they say,
"We're open to all them. That's your
rules. If you allow that, I will come
and do the call to prayer up in a
mosque, etc." If you say, "No, we don't
allow that," then I'm not coming to your
country. So, if you allow it, you cannot
come and call us hypocrites. I mean,
would you allow that? Like what Myron
says, "Would you allow that in your
country?" No, we wouldn't. But we're
we're consistent. Why? Because we're
saying we don't. And just cuz we don't
Look, it's like somebody coming and
saying, "Oh, so Sorry for the crude
example here, whatever, okay? Maybe
Myron understand from this analogy,
okay?" If somebody comes and says, "I
don't mind you going out with my
sister."
Yeah, okay. I Me? Bro, you're married to
my sister. There's no girlfriend,
boyfriend.
He's not going to come and say, "Yeah,
but I allow you to date my sister." I
don't give a damn what the hell you
allow, bro. Just cuz you allow that
doesn't mean I have to do the same thing
with you. That's the difference here. We
have a set of values, we do it. So,
someone can't come and say to us, "Oh,
and and argument sake, if I was to go
and um
Did you understand what I'm saying? You
know, not sure. So, just cuz you guys
allow that, doesn't mean we abide by
that. Like you're saying, "Yes, we can
all religion respect religion." That's
fine. In Islamic rule, the Christians
and the Jews have lived under our rule
in their own places of livelihood
wherever they are. They have their own
rules, whatever they want to do, no
problem. They cannot bring it into the
Islamic sides of things where we are
living, if that makes sense.
Okay, so what
>> Bible reading [__] but most
Christians are are that aren't [__]
right? And remember, this is just
American Christians. Christians all over
the place don't [__] If you look at
Eastern Europe, they're all super
anti-Semitic. They're all [__] Okay,
so wait. So, Orthodox Christians are
super uh anti-Semitic Christians. Thank
you. Anti-Semitism comes from
Christians. The Crusaders. It is the
think of infidel and anti-Semitism is
made and created by Christians. They're
the real anti-Semites. We're not. We're
not. We're not. The prophet's wife was
ethnically Jewish. Okay? We are not
anti-Semitic. If anything, the
Christians are the real anti-Semites.
Shout out to them. Yeah, but like they
don't [__] with the Jews. Let me just
say that cuz anti-Semitism Okay, and I
disagree with that statement. Shout out
to them. Shout out. Like this is this is
this statement is anti-Semitic. Come on.
You know, this attitude of being against
Jews because of who they are. This is
this is I believe Islamic this is
disgusting. This is wrong. You cannot
come and pick on Jews because they're
Jews, bro. What's the difference in
picking on Muslims cuz they're Muslims?
This is not what our religion teaches.
You told me to respect Myron.
You know, you're not a representative of
Islam, but even you saying that I
believe that's wrong, bro. I believe
it's wrong. is a fake word. It it but
it's your it's your mentality
approaching think that that we're guest
here. Yeah, I think we're guest here.
That is that is We were Myron, Myron, we
were born here. No.
The Islamic faith and the the the
religion of Islam, you are a guest as a
Muslim in
Here's why the That I agree. I agree.
I'm so sorry, Sneako.
I'm sorry. He's right, bro. I mean, if
the day comes you you we are they are
guest there. I mean, the reality is they
should abide by those laws, which they
don't. You're born there, you're their
citizen. That's what Sneako's saying,
and he's right. But in reality, bro,
when the day comes, they kick you all
out, you all going, bro. You all
Mexicans, every single one of you guys.
They're kicking us out. And include me.
I'm going to They're going to kick me
out here as well.
I don't belong here. Your logic is
flawed.
Because
for example, if you're a white guy and
you're an atheist, by Myron's the logic,
you're not
you're not a guest. You're at home. You
could be a white atheist, a white
Satanist for that matter, and this is
still your home and you own it. Yeah,
but that's the reality, Sneako. One
thing you need to understand, that is
the reality of what Myron's trying to
say. That is true. They will accept
their own and kick anything that's
different out. They would genuinely do
that and I and I think Sneako is being
hopeful in the legislation and etc., you
know, but that's the reality.
>> What if you convert to Islam? If you say
la ilaha illallah, you say there's only
one worthy of worship except God, then
you're now a guest. So, this doesn't
make any sense?
Your faith does Do
but but Sneako, that's what it is. If
you especially say la ilaha illallah,
that's what the thing I want to say to
Myron. Where he's got a chip on his
shoulder. Bro, they're not going to be
happy with you, by the way. Yeah, okay,
let me make this clear, okay? They would
never have Like the statement that
Sneako just said now, cuz you say la
ilaha illallah. Bro, just for that
statement alone, they don't want nothing
to do with you. And Myron, a message to
you, Allah says in the Quran, "The
disbelievers will never be happy with
you." The more you come and say they're
trying to take over, you got a chip on
your shoulder, trying to prove
something, it's like you're trying to
suck up to them. And it's never going to
work. They will only accept you if you
leave your faith. Then they'll say
you're one of us. Other than that, bro,
even then they won't. They'll look at
you and say you're brown, dark dark guy,
black guy, bro. You're okay, then.
Bye-bye. Your religion You believe in a
religion that's not going to help you,
bro. Your skin color is going to get you
in trouble.
>> determine what you believe in does not
determine whether or not it's your
country. It's your birth certificate.
It's your passport.
United States United States. Am I a
guest in my home? Bro, we are guests
here. What do you We were We are guests
here. We were born here. Yes, but our
religion our our religion Like okay,
fine example to Sneako so you understand
that. For example, that girl who
traveled to ISIS etc. whatever, she was
a British citizen. They didn't let her
back in. You're not coming back in. Why?
Cuz she's Bengali or whatever it is, for
that matter. They did not let her back
back in. There's double standards, bro.
There is double standards. That's why
we're saying they they they they even
like looking at ways of, you know,
taking people's citizenship off them.
This is what we're talking about,
Sneako. You need to understand they
don't really accept you. So, now your
faith makes you a guest.
Yes, if you're going to Yes, to a
degree, yeah. Yes, so you said that's
not what you said, yes. So, so it's your
faith, right? Why is atheist not guest?
Why Muslim guest?
That's to a degree to a degree or
Yeah, but but because obviously
everything is like nuanced. Like nothing
is absolute. But like the point I'm
trying to make is is that
the Islamic faith as as This is not a
Muslim country. So, therefore What about
Catholics? Are our Catholics guests?
Because it was it was founded by
Protestants.
I mean, we get the point here. I think
I'm going to end the video. We're going
to get the point here.
But yeah,
um
there's nothing else to say. I just want
to say a message to Myron. Myron, like
genuinely, I don't understand your
problem. I don't understand what you're
trying to prove. Again, I don't mean to
do this video to like
disrespect you in any way. I think
you're you're a Muslim brother, but
things that you say, I just want to know
why you have the chip on your shoulder.
Why you bugging out etc. when people are
just going to pray, not stopping
anywhere. Really reflect on that. And
you know what? I like I said before, I
have nothing personal against you. I'm
just saying what you're saying is wrong
and it is harmful. Now, if I believed
and I had evidence that they are doing
this at eight kilometers, I'll be
against you. I'll I'll tell you. I'll
I'll I'll I'll I'll I'll I'll I'll I'll
I'll I'll I'll I'll I'll But we're going
to be linking up with the brothers. You
can watch our stream on the live.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. This is the new Sadaqa
Jariyah in town. We are teaching people
how to pray. And every time they pray,
you get to share in that reward. And
when they teach their children, and
their children's children,
the reward continues. Every Fajr, Dhuhr,
Asr, Maghrib, Isha, Tarawih, Tahajjud.
Every recitation, you share in the
reward. For just £100, you can help
teach 20 to 60 people nightly learn how
to pray salah. Donate today. Donate
today. Donate today.